Ocean Spray cranberry juice has been
around forever the single most effective
commercial marketing campaign in the
company's history was a man going down
the street on some sort of skateboard
drinking it and listening to Fleetwood
Mac in its history it is impossible for
me to be able to communicate to this
room how big of an elephant in the room
what I'm talking about is for reselling
there is a collision course that is
happening between math and art and the
greatest way for you to extract value is
to bet so much more on Art in the face
of it not being as interesting to bet on
as math the day-to-day tactics of what
I'm saying you take your product and
whether through reaching out to
influencers at scale and paying which
can be very underpriced or overpriced
depending on your skill set of
understanding what you're buying and you
should put some real homework into it
but more importantly your ability to
create internal production capabilities
to produce ungodly amounts of short form
video content